grab a basket of unlimited breadsticks
and get ready for an impromptu dance
number
[Music]
it's the resident evil fans have been
begging for for years one punch right in
the tent now i consider myself a pretty
big resident evil fan i played most of
the games loved re village for reasons
so when a new tv show was announced i
was like
so whether you've seen the show or not
like it or not we're gonna have fun
breaking down this season it's
connection to the resident evil universe
and theories for season two welcome to
london 2036 or as i like to call it
london under boris johnson this is our
protagonist jade wesker and if that last
name sounds familiar to you that's
because she's the daughter of big re
villain albert wesker but as we'll find
out later this albert is hiding a big
secret it's been 14 years since the
quote-unquote end of the world which
happened in 2022 and the show will go
back and forth between these two time
periods we'll see old jade in europe in
the year 2036 and 14 year old jade in
south africa in the year 2022 moving
into this wholesome town run by umbrella
called new raccoon city jade and her
twin sister billy are the new kids in
town having moved here because of their
father albert's job now you may be
asking yourself jade and billy sure
don't look like twins well it's
complicated their father used a
surrogate to combine his sperm with eggs
from two different women so even though
they came out of the same woman they
biologically have two different moms and
if you think that's confusing just wait
until later the main arc of the 2022
storyline revolves around the girls
adjusting to life in new raccoon city
while getting behind the mystery of what
their father does for umbrella the 2036
story revolves around jade trying to get
back to her husband and daughter after a
botched research experiment you see the
world in 2036 is held loosely together
by a group of independent freeholds we
get a brief glimpse of this in episode 1
with the major ones being umbrella
amazonia fortress scandinavia sahai and
the faith of the billions of humans on
earth in 2022 only 300 million remain in
2036. jade believes that the t virus the
virus responsible for turning people
into zombies will naturally weaken over
time and that weakness will manifest in
the zombies becoming smarter i'm not
exactly sure how that works out but
let's just go with it so she goes out
every day investigating different zombie
hordes looking for any signs that they
may be working as a pack jade has found
herself as a part of a faction known as
the university a team of academics who
travel the world on a boat collecting
artifacts from the past the hope is is
that their work can be used as the
foundation for starting civilization
over again jade also has a partner arjun
and daughter b arjun is not b's
biological father and we never find out
who that dad really is likely a plot
point saved for season two now you might
be asking yourself where's billy we'll
get into that in a bit on her journey
jade finds herself mixed up with a
faction known as the brotherhood these
crazies believe the zombies are a
blessing and that they were sent from
god for man to control it's in their
stronghold an underground german bunker
from world war ii that jade witnesses
something astounding the brotherhood has
been able to control the zombies who
power a turbine thus making electricity
even crazier as how they get the zombies
to do this in the first place they feed
a unique zombie build in the captioning
as mother zero mother zero then
communicates via pheromones instructing
the zombies to move we'll later learn
that these zombies have terrible
eyesight in hearing the result of their
organs slowly decaying over time so they
primarily rely on smell to find their
prey jade's escape from the brotherhood
sees her chainsawing off mother zero's
head so she can later experiment on it
turns out mother zero uses specific
pheromones or scents to communicate with
others if jade could harness this power
she could theoretically instruct zombies
to kill an enemy or stay away from an
ally it could be groundbreaking for
humanity but first teenage drama can it
be cool
[Music]
i hate to say it but we're sandwiched
all right jade and billy discover that
their dad has a secret lab in their
basement a lab which not only has
information about their origins but also
the raccoon city cover-up of 1998 they
watch a video of their father
investigating a woman named lisa trevor
who some of you may remember from the
original resident evil game when
confronted with this albert says the
person in the video who sounds a lot
like him wasn't him that's because it
wasn't to make this show even more
insane albert is one of three clone
copies of the original albert wesker who
we meet at the beginning of episode 7
wearing his iconic leather outfit and
shades these clones are creatively named
albert burt and alby the original albert
who we'll call alpha wesker is obsessed
with self-preservation in fact that's a
line that's brought up all throughout
the season any weskers you're all about
one thing
self-preservation we're weskers
self-preservation is what we do he was
so obsessed with prolonging his life
that he created three clones of himself
to aid him in his research in developing
some sort of immortality here's the
kicker alpha wesker didn't have time to
raise these clones from birth to adult
age he needed them working as soon as
possible so he sped up their development
speed having these clones go from birth
to age 20 in only 6 months as you can
imagine this caused a myriad of health
problems and yes i just wanted to use
the word myriad this is why albert jaden
billy's father extracts their blood and
injects it into himself he genetically
engineered them so that their blood
could help him live of course he kept
this a secret from his daughters and
their right to question whether he
actually loved them or was just keeping
them around for his own survival when
it's found out by umbrella that alpha
wesker was conducting these experiments
in a facility buried in the arclay
mountains a location those familiar with
resident evil will recognize he decides
to destroy the evidence killing alby in
the process i'm not sure how this was
destroying evidence since the body is
still there regardless both albert and
bert survive albert will later go on to
become a rising star in umbrella and
starts a family with jade and billy
while bert would be locked away poor
bert alpha wesker on the other hand will
go on to die in a volcano in 2009 which
can be seen in resident evil 5. albert
has been helping evelyn marcus the newly
minted ceo of umbrella perfect a
mind-altering drug known as joy
something that can eliminate depression
ocd and anxiety from its users a drug
that could change the world eliminating
negative thoughts and putting an end to
suicide evelyn wants to restructure
umbrella from this bioweapons company
towards more family-friendly consumer
products hence the production of joy
they even have merch and a mascot it's
implied that she took over as ceo from
her father dr james marcus one of the
founding members of umbrella we never
really found out what happened to him in
this series version in the games he died
in 1988 however eve hides a secret she
has a mystery mutant man in a tank
she'll later tell bert that this is her
quote special project is this special
project her father it kind of looks
similar to the mimicry marcus monster
found in resident evil 0 which took the
form of james marcus it could also be
william birkin one of the lead
scientists behind the t-virus who
injected himself with the virus after
being shot hoping it would keep him
alive this boss also has this claw-like
hand william birkin is also mentioned in
episode 5 when jade and billy uncover
confidential files with his name all
over it so i want to hear from you guys
who you think this person could be
evelyn also shows that joy has the
ability to control others she shows how
this rabid dog can be easily soothed so
there's obviously some nefarious things
going on with it not to mention that joy
is made from a small dose of the t-virus
the final episode sees jade breaking
into umbrella to save her sister she was
captured after it was discovered she was
bitten by a t-virus-infected dog the
strange thing however is that billy has
not turned into one of the zombies
something about the makeup of her blood
has made her resistant even though she's
resistant she still suffers from its
side effects including frequent
hallucinations and bouts of rage she can
still also infect others she'll end up
attacking simon eve's son who was
helping jaden her escape after he
discovered his mom was drugging his
other mom with joy so that she'd forget
how [ __ ] their marriage was yeah it's a
little complicated thistle culminates in
a climactic showdown will eve enlist
albert's help in finding a cure for her
son or will she
okay wasn't expecting that yep she kills
her own son putting the company before
blood a final escape ensues where albert
sacrifices himself by creating a huge
explosion so that his daughters can
escape he proves that the weskers can do
more than just think about themselves
the umbrella facility goes up in flames
but not before we see that tank monster
emerge from the rubble this is likely
the start of the worldwide spread of the
t virus as we'll later see adult jade is
the number two survivor of new raccoon
city number one likely being her sister
but what happened between jade and billy
leaving new raccoon and the events of
2036. part of this is answered in
episode 5's cliffhanger where it's
revealed billy is still alive and
working for umbrella under eve no less
but even that is a lie after we find out
billy actually controls eve using a
series of electrodes implanted in her
brain as far as we know billy is pulling
the strings at umbrella or at least is
high up in the company we don't see it
in the show but somewhere in those 14
years jade abandons billy and the two
develop differing opinions on how the
world should be shaped jade wants to
hold on to the past well billy wants to
erase it for billy the past is nothing
but pain their storyline culminates in
jade being captured she wants all the
artifacts and research the university
has collected to be destroyed but jade
uses her newly acquired zombie
pheromones to attract hundreds of
zombies who i guess were just chilling
nearby the university also has a defense
mechanism of its own a giant
t-virus-infected crocodile who they pull
from the back of their ship yeah that's
a thing throughout the series we've seen
how the t-virus affects cell growth in
different animals like the caterpillar
here and spider here jade has found a
way to implant electrodes into its brain
allowing her to wake up and put to sleep
this monster at her will so not only do
we have an army of zombies attacking but
this giant ass crocodile as well in the
commotion jade is able to escape but the
odd thing here is that she's not
attacked or chased by any of the zombies
later when her daughter bee lands on the
island looking for her mom she too is
not eaten by the giant crocodile the
exact opposite actually billy will
notice this strange occurrence before
blasting the crocodile to kingdom come
and she wonders if jade somehow altered
her daughter's dna however i think
there's a more logical explanation in
episode 7 jade tells her daughter to
escape with arjun and take the green
duffel bag i think this duffle bag must
be covered in the red pheromone which
repels anything infected with the
t-virus this would also explain how none
of the zombies attacked her when she
escaped as she would have been covered
in this billy ends up surviving the
zombie attack using her umbrella drones
and ultimately confronts her sister and
niece she tells her that the t-virus
stripped away all her fears and anxiety
and let her be her true self this
sadistic killer a killer she said was
created by jade's actions she goes so
far as to call jade the real virus
everyone around her dies after all and
she lists a bunch of names two of which
are characters we haven't yet met the
first is kim the other hiroki these are
probably characters that we'll meet in
later seasons billy shoots jade and
kidnaps her daughter leaving jade to die
alone maybe billy can use bee's blood to
fix her tainted blood not exactly sure
why she didn't just kill her here seems
a little sus we can take this as her
being around if there's a season two but
the biggest tie-in to resident evil
happens when jade opens the note her dad
gave her before he died it's of someone
they're supposed to get in contact with
and that someone is ada wong long-time
resident evil fans will recognize her
from the games she's this mysterious spy
type character who undoubtedly has a lot
of information about umbrella's past i
get the feeling we haven't even begun to
scratch the surface on what really
happened between jade and billy leaving
new raccoon city and their falling out i
wouldn't be surprised if season 2
continues the same format of hopping
back and forth between these two
timelines whether you liked it or hated
it resident evil has set up a lot for
its next season from the mystery mutant
the sisters falling out and how evelyn
goes from the head of umbrella to
billy's mind-controlled puppet but what
did you think of the season i want to
hear your thoughts and theories below i
hope you enjoyed this video be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember
finished